et oui alors on va revenir sur l'image
qui a fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
hier soir c'était lors de l'annonce du
vainqueur à 20h à Hénin-Beaumont dans le
Nord et regardez les militantes étaient
très très en colère celle-ci je vous le
dis on va la repasser deux fois voilà
pour vous dire regardez très fort
regarde
[Musique]
incroyable franchement mais alors je
vous la passez regardez collage une dame
derrière vraiment parce que c'est vrai
que elle est incroyable toutes les
années derrière elle est elle est
incroyable regarde c'est fou moi je l'ai
regardé 200 fois
[Musique]
ça me dégoûte
ça me dégoûte et il y a deux gars il a
raison les deux gars là les deux gars là
ils se tient ils ont l'air contents en
fait j'ai pas compris ça c'était
incroyable alors ça il y a eu ça il y a
une des militantes aussi que vous avez
vu dans la vidéo qui a réagi pour la
Voix du Nord peu de temps après les
résultats regardez étriers de désespoir
de de colère voilà parce que je suis
quand même en prenant tous les membres
dégoûté quoi je veux dire que ça soit
encore lui je misais beaucoup sur
on avait espoir cette fois-ci c'était
c'était la bonne que Marine allait
passer
[Musique]
alors ça c'était incroyable dans cette
vidéo elle a énormément tourné vraiment
je l'ai reçu moi une dizaine de fois
hier et pour la Darkan vous voulez vous
remontrer cette image qui nous a fait
beaucoup rire il y a 5 ans on y voit un
soutien de François Fillon réagir à
l'annonce des résultats regardez ça
aussi c'est cadeau c'est pour nous deux
la presse la presse
[Applaudissements]
on dirait qu'il a été habité le gars
non non
la presse la presse
la presse
incroyable
ça c'est un petit cadeau et du côté des
soutien de Marine Le Pen on est tombé
aussi sur une grande déçu elle y croyait
vraiment et visuellement à la
visiblement la elle a perdu tout espoir
hier regardez
[Musique]
j'ai regardé j'ai regardé une dizaine de
fois c'est franchement il faut tous
qu'on les voit deux fois en fait
une fois qu'on le sait on est on est
tous voilà sur la personne en fait et
regarder le la déception quoi c'est un
truc de fou c'est comme Benjamin
Castaldi je dis que c'était Eric elle
est de remplacer sur Fifa 16
demain bien entendu à 18h40 pour le
moment regardez ça
[Musique]
bien appeler
nos équipes de TPMP étaient là-bas et
ils ont pu recueillir sa réaction
quelques instants après la défaite de
Marine Le Pen regardez la France
[Musique]
voilà
franchement Marine Le Pen a fait une
belle campagne elle méritait vraiment de
gagner
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'elle est pas dans l'histoire
on la capte pas mais la meilleure c'est
elle la meilleure elle va tourner
partout elle est incroyable on l'adore
elle balance tout hein mais c'est pas du
et ça ce sont des images TPMP voilà oui
ça n'arrive que chez nous ça
[Musique]
très franchement Marine Le Pen a fait
une belle campagne elle méritait
vraiment de gagner
et
franchement il a beau se déguiser on a
tous reconnu Gilbert dez
[Applaudissements]
alors vous en doutez les résultats de
l'élection ont des plus bien entendu à
beaucoup de soutien de Marine Le Pen
dont ce monsieur qui est vraiment hors
de lui hier lors de l'annonce du
vainqueur regardez le pauvre il pète un
câble il est pas bien
non non mais non mais non c'est pas
possible
bande de
[ __ ] sérieux
vous avez rien compris restez dans votre
merde ma carte de vote
ma carte
de votre terminez 5 ans terminé
tu peux couper
[Rires]
le fils derrière qui est hôtel Les
doliane c'est mon daron
franchement il y a eu des trucs
incroyables hier au premier tour on
avait envoyé des équipes pour suivre la
soirée électorale du QG d'Emmanuel
Macron et on était tombé sur cette
pépite de Jonathan il avait mal accepté
de venir sur notre plateau le lendemain
regarde
OK
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]